foreign
every second together counts because
Michelle knows her time with her
daughter may be rapidly running out
Sofia has a rare deadly and incurable
disease called tub foray leukodystrophy
now 12 she first presented symptoms
nearly a decade ago
case scenarios the children die within
12 months
a month and I had no idea how long she
was going to live for you know the
doctors told us there's nothing you can
do
and I think it's probably the most
devastating
kind of news that you can you know for
any parent to hear
I couldn't accept it
that's why I decided to do something
about it
at first that something was to raise
money for research but as Sophia's
condition worsened from a healthy
toddler to a child unable to walk or
talk Michelle took Research into her own
hands a scientist by trade she set up a
company to find a cure I feel like
because we set up this company we are
finally in a driving seat and finding a
treatment for her
within those timelines you know that we
believe
will be on time for her
the company is based in Oxford and has
teamed up with a leading Children's
Hospital in America hopeful it will
reach clinical trials within the next
two years and one of the most horrible
things is that a lot of these children
don't actually make it into late
teenagers
and hopefully by stopping the
progression of this disease it could
offer them
a better quality of life as well as
an extension to their lives as well this
is a potential Game Changer it is it is
a potential Game Changer yes
part of the reason why there's no cure
for this disease yet is because it was
actually only identified eight years ago
in 2014 and the other reason is because
it's incredibly rare it's thought to
only affect between 60 and 90 newborns
in Britain each year and just over 1600
worldwide
for those it does affect it is a ticking
Time Bomb but Michelle says Sophia
doesn't let it get to her and that
they'll never give up hope of finding a
cure either Bennett Sky News Oxford